there was always the fear fear fear of
failure I think that was my biggest
nightmare when people tell me like how
about like where you were persecuted why
like there was like a warrant for your
arrest her
I really didn't care about that what I
was always worried about is that the
next show would not be as good that we
are not going to perform I remember like
when I was taken to questioning for six
hours I told my team if we did a bad
show they would win so I will always
always worried about making the best job
I can do because that's basically your
captain
if you're not good enough nobody would
really care about you and I always
thought of this as my biggest support
maybe called as a creative fear but it
was the fear of failure the fear of
judgment especially and and the society
that we're living in right now when
people are very very very fast to judge
there's basically absolutely no mercy
I imagine that maybe some of the veteran
legends in entertainment may be there
when they if they had social media 30 40
50 years ago people will be very
unforgiving and maybe their carry would
have ended very very fast very soon like
we see now I think social media is as a
huge driver of that fear you know
people's opinion instantly and it can
crush someone it can crush people they
can end people's career even so I on a
personal level that was my fear fear of
failure on a bigger level there's
another kind of fear which is the fear
that is the biggest asset of any fascist
government and it doesn't really matter
if you are a person living under a
dictatorship in the Middle East or under
a right-wing government anywhere else in
the Western world where they use fear
patriotism and xenophobia to drive the
masses it it's the same thing
fear is an incredible
mover of the masses it brainwashes
people it makes people accept and even
vote for something that's against their
own personal interest totally out of
fear and speaking about that particular
point it is the same reason why
fascism's have a very poor sense of
humor because when you have satire
you're not afraid anymore they don't
want you thinking and-and-and-and and
they didn't want you they don't want you
to think and laugh they want you to be
in constant state of fear if you're
you're laughing and then you're
basically laughing and they're
brainwashing techniques and their use of
fear and it's not effective anymore but
they don't want that as a matter of fact
there been stories about I think Hitler
that one of the first people that he
have abolished were there see realists
and and the and the satirist I don't
know if that's true or not the time it
sounds intelligence on that side so
that's why satire is an incredible
antidote to fear and the people in power
they will try to belittle you they will
call you a joke a clown am a fool but in
the process of doing that they're making
a fool out of themselves they're
becoming the clown and they are the ones
who are becoming a joke
you